[Musique]
selon une amende
on savait possibles principalement des
missions à des fins fiscales alléger ses
vidéos supplémentaires
d'accord mais le sort de l'épave et
l'espoir en fait ça dépend de ce soir à
l'extérieur une dizaine de personnes
forment une file d'attenté officieuse
tu aimes ans et deux supplémentaires sur
vannes donné le soir à qui veut
et certaines personnes ici n'ont même
pas 30 ans partait en vacances
si on peut les prévoir éventuellement
une amélioration des situations moment
on sera prêt moi c'est mon grand père il
avait passé quatre mois j'ai pas vu
parce qu'il a un cancer et qui est
toujours pas vaccinées dans six mois je
suis vacciné ça me permet d'aller le
voir
[Musique]
l'infection peut se produire par l'un de
nos trois points d'entrée dieu n'est
bouche c'est pourquoi ce masque est très
utile au quotidien
on n'est pas sûr du rapport coût
avantage c'est à dire que tu as l'air
bien plus con que ça ne te protège et
cette séquence on en rit cannes
elle sera peut-être diffuser dans un an
lancé par new avec un string sur la
gueule et des yeux désabusés
on dira tu te rappelles fin 2021 en
d'enrayer reste un petit peu quand même
dans l'air du temps en parlant du
télétravail et je vais vous montrer des
images qui sont assez parlantes qui met
en lumière
l'inégalité hommes femmes à la maison
dont vous voyez c'est une photo avec
deux longues sur laquelle on voit la
femme qui s'agite dans tous les sens
avec la ville les enfants son ordi et
l'homme impassible devant son écran donc
s'atteler à sa tâche unique qui est
celle de travailler voilà c'est assez
édifiante
en revanche il épouse la morphologie des
occupants absolument c'est si tu n'es
plus haut à un homme alors c'est un
fauteuil de bureau donc
traditionnellement en tout cas au 19e
ce sont les hommes qui est donc vous
pouvez vous tenir confortablement génial
mais c'est clairement le profil de la
femme castratrice et profondément
mauvaise et méchante et ça on n'en parle
pas souvent et parfois il est nommé sous
peu et qui sont la grosse pomme qu'on
appelle les canards et on n'en parle pas
ces enquêtes
azizi de tuer doha
un grand longuet
ouah je viens ici c'est un fauteuil
d'hommes qu'on appelle même un couillard
un coup iard oui et pourquoi moyens
pourquoi non moi je pense que le nom est
suffisamment évocateur vous avez pas
besoin non plus de rester à cause de moi
ça s'appelait vraiment commis à cause de
sa forme je t'assure que c'est vrai
[Rires]
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui t'a pris je pense que je
voulais faire une fleur à la base mais
j'ai mélangé de délire si tu aimes les
caps tu sais tu n es bistouquette battu
fait la fusion et tu finis bistouquette
un inquiétant mais oui c'est suite à
cette phrase à pauline une grande
respiration et on y va
lancement c'est donc le lancement que
mike richards oui j'assume
vos histoires insolites charles on
commence avec un constat inquiétant de
points les humains naissent avec des
pénis des pénis de plus en plus petit
oui c'est les fruits à coques steel hugh
la noisette hier à des animaux qui voit
là quoique bon c'est une tueriie
franchement c'est un vrai orgasme picard
est vraiment elle établit le lien très
concret entre la pollution en
particulier les fameux perturbateurs
endocriniens et la réduction de la
taille des organes génitaux autrement
dit la hausse de la pollution entraîne
une baisse de la taille en particulier
des pénis mais ce n'est pas le plus
inquiétant la scientifiques constatent
également que le niveau de sperme chez
les hommes a diminué de 50% en 40 ans et
elle prévoit une crise donna de la
natalité dans les décennies qui viennent
donc ça sens où l'amour eu le coeur des
filles n'ont déjà rien
des frites et les filles mais ça va pas
non a lille on s assure la bruche chez
les filles mais ça va pas leur coeur
ample mais ça va pas non sans avoir eu
de vainqueur des frites etc
c'est une remarque culinaire est pas
inclusive profit les mini dos reis
trimestre et ça me suis à débloquer sur
ce mot tegra tomahawk et du orifices dib
un jeu trop balle ah bah ça vole pas ou
par ici lagence l écossais sont quoi
exactement cette association
bah c'est à dire faire des concours se
ressemblent sans se ressembler pour
faire des thèmes qui aimeraient seconde
sera ce que nous monsieur au travail sur
le plateau on fait une émission de télé
merci a bientot bonne journée et la pose
du coup en fait l'appareil 45 buts
vendredi on a pris un peu plus de 45 45
quoi qu'il arrive donc au label arnold
schwarzenegger qui serait l'homme le
plus qualifié pour faire face aux
extraterrestres ou sané est absolument
sans transition mais c'est sérieux aussi
c'est en tout cas l'avis de 2000
britanniques qui ont utilisé son départ
une chaîne de télé avec cette question à
votre avis quelle serait la personnalité
humaine la plus apte à gérer la riposte
face à une invasion extraterrestre on
leur a proposé une liste de noms et
malgré ses 73 ans choisit arrive
nettement en tête des suffrages
internet c'est aussi le lieu de
l'improbable là où kevin bacon reprend
une chanson des backstreet boys
devant des alpagas
[Musique]
l'acteur révélé dans le film footloose
en 1984 s'amuse ainsi sur son compte tic
toc
après tout il a une guitare une ferme et
un public tout trouvé